there are many theoretical reasons for
believing that there is much more to our
universe than the part that we can see
and this idea is called the multiverse
it's the idea that there are other
pocket universes far beyond what we can
actually see within our observable
horizon and that those universes could
have very different properties to our
own so this is almost like science
fiction when I first heard about this
idea I thought it's not testable I'm an
experimental scientist and you know if
something can be tested for me it
remains theoretical or speculation so
when I met Matt Johnson and he suggested
to me that there was a way to test this
idea I became very excited because you
know we have to be very lucky to be able
to test this idea but if it can be
tested is you know discovering another
universe is an amazing thing and the way
that this could be tested is very early
on when these bubble universes are very
close together they can collide and that
collision can cause a perturbation or
improves in what we see in the very
earliest light in our universe the
Cosmic Microwave Background and so we've
developed these algorithms to try to
extract such a signature from this data
and while we were doing this
observational program we realized that
the predictions for what this signal
should look like should also be revised
because when these collisions happen
it's a very violent event it could
actually cause the destruction of one of
the bubble universes and the
mathematical techniques that we had to
try to predict that signature but not
enough and we learned that we have to
put in Stein's equations for general
relativity on a computer and do this
problem numerically and so that's what
we did we actually simulated whole
universes in the computer we collided
them and we were able to extract the
observational signature this now allows
us to carry on this observational
program for looking for this signature
and very excited about that